[Music]
sergey sobol is a miner
he works 300 meters underground
in ukraine stepnayam mine
it was and remains dangerous
what's important is that we are safe do
our jobs and get home safely
by we he means the 300 odd men who work
shifts in the mine that operates 24 7.
he's been working here for four years
now but he's been a miner for much
longer
my father and grandfather worked in the
mines
were proud of giving her compatriots
heating and electricity
has been in operation for over 50 years
it's one that survived the collapse of
the soviet union and continued to
provide regular wages to its employees
this is not to be assumed in eastern
ukraine
hermione here earns the equivalent of
about 800 euros per month
a lot of money in this poor region
hey italian you're so brown have you
been on holiday
when i was a kid i would hear words like
mine miners and i'd see men wearing
makeup at least that's what i thought
today my team is like my family
his own family symbolizes the fate of
ukraine as a whole
the 35 year old is from dambass where
war between pro-russian separatists and
the ukrainian army has raged since 2014.
[Music]
when his mind shut down because of the
war in 2017 he and his family fled to
the west
to the small town of peshawtraviensk
[Music]
there are hardly any jobs left there
almost everyone has gone except the old
people
according to the un over 13 000 people
have died in seven years of war
and though there is a peace agreement
the conflict frequently flares up
right now the whole world is waiting to
see what will happen as russian troops
continue to amass on the border
i didn't want my child to be born in a
place where people have to be scared of
going to work
where
conflict was preceded by what is known
as the revolution of dignity or the
maidan revolution
a violent uprising in the ukrainian
capital kiev in 2014
that ended with the overthrow of the
pro-russian president
afterwards the new pro-western
government turned away from its soviet
past and opted for europe
but this is not easy
particularly in eastern ukraine which is
dominated by the coal industry
most of the mines are in areas
controlled by the separatists
only four of the remaining ones turn a
profit
including the stipmaya mine
but that is meant to close down in three
years time
ukraine is also shifting away from coal
[Music]
the fate of the thousands of families
who depend on coal is thus uncertain
[Music]
and sergey sorbol has mixed feelings
when he goes underground
especially when he thinks about the past
the miners had a good life in the soviet
union
ukraine was rich then
but in the years of independence our
country was plundered and depleted
[Music]
is not alone in harboring these feelings
in eastern ukraine
[Music]
on the other hand
nobody wants to turn back the clocks and
return to the ussr
[Music]
you